I'm using this comment to piggyback and continue this conversation
because this is also why men leave women when women get sick
and I always think about Yolanda Hadid
if you don't know Yolanda Hadid was married to David Foster
she was a real housewife of Beverly Hills
and then she got or had been dealing with
but it got really bad chronic Lyme disease
and she started to be really
really ill for a long time
pretty much bedridden on a lot of medication
she had a nurse and like
really shortly after that
David Foster and Yolanda Hadid got divorced
and this isn't conjecture
this was actually said on the show
but that like
she forgave him because she's like
he didn't sign up to have a sick wife
he didn't sign up to be a caretaker
yes you fucking did
when you got married and he couldn't handle it
so he left because there's a certain type of man
who is only in a long term relationship with a woman
to be taken care of and catered to
and when someone within the family
whether it's the wife or a new child
needs more of that love care
and attention at that certain time
they can't take a backseat
they don't understand that a partnership
a relationship a family
is the push and pull of energy and effort and affection
because if that man isn't gonna take care of his own child
and jealous of the care and needs of their own child
just imagine if you got sick